d'ailleurs après réflexion que doit-on
dire de ces propos d' emmanuel macron
avant-hier c'est une vraie avancée
concernant l'égalité femmes hommes
c'est surtout sur la question des
violences faites aux femmes qu'il est
intervenu mon une il y a eu des choses
intéressantes comme par exemple le
recueil des plaintes dans les instituts
médicaux les unités médico judiciaires
sans avoir à porter plainte
d'abord c'est à dire que avant il
fallait porter plainte et ensuite on en
voyait des femmes en institut médico
judiciaire ça c'est une chose très
importante parce qu'on sait que les
femmes hésitent à porter plainte elles
peuvent plus facilement aller à
l'hôpital dire voilà mon état alors ça
c'est une ça fait une avancée il y a
aussi le fait de porter plainte une pré
planète en ligne et à ce moment les
associations peuvent prendre le relais
main lors nous sommes particulièrement
déçus il ya aussi d'autres choses je le
consentement qui l'âge de consentement
ce qu'on donne
oui mais lors nous sommes
particulièrement déçus c'est sur la
question du budget parce que bon le
budget de 30 millions en 2016
il a été ramené en 2010 est de façon
drastique par monsieur macro et là
mettant il est revenu à 30 millions donc
il n'y a pas d'augmentation du budget
donc vous verrez que tout cela ne soit
que des paroles nous faisons confiance
aux féministes françaises vous
connaissez ce ne soit pas que des
paroles et justement noah nous députés
là aussi un les députés progressistes
députés qui sont pour la question des et
de l'égalité entre les hommes et les
femmes et surtout la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
il faut qu'ils agissent if parce qu'il
ya aussi des lobbyings adam l'assemblée
nationale des femmes qui défendent ces
lois donc on fait confiance à ces
personnes mais nous pas contre en
martinique
ce que nous souhaitons c'est que les
choses se passent autrement que par
rapport aux questions des violences
faites aux femmes
je crois qu'il n'y a que l'on voulait
georges arnaud aubin je crois qu'on n'a
pas besoin d'eux que soient mieux
accompagnés ne serait ce que par les
collectivités
sur le plan des opérations qui peuvent
être faites moi par exemple la formation
du personnel des municipalités des
collectivités de la police municipale ça
ne demande pas de defaud particulier
puisque l'action de démunis
simplement qu'il faut simplement
s'adresser dire c'est une volonté
politique c'est dire que c'est une
priorité pour nous le cnfpt peut mettre
en place et formation ça coûte pas un
centime à la municipalité seulement au
cnfpt émanant de plusieurs est tout à
fait prête à mettre en place et
formation ce n'est pas fait est ce assez
c'est quand même très dommage par
exemple dès le début de l'année on sera
en janvier que les municipalités vote
dans leurs budgets que pour le 25
novembre pour le 8 mars
il y aura au moins une banderole de 200
euros qui sera fixé sur la sueur sur la
mairie je crois que ce sont des petites
choses qui sont importantes et par
exemple on parle de l'éducation
nationale la formation des personnes
éducation nationale mais ce sont des
choses qui existent déjà qui en fait
quand je dis qu'ils existent qui peuvent
se faire déjà demandé dans des
directives précédentes ça ne se fait pas
cette décision politique doté où doivent
être prises par kiel après concrètement
si les maires écoute vous leur demandez
quoi on leur demande de mettre dans
leurs budgets dès janvier voilà ces
choses là et que ça soit une priorité
pour eux lutter contre les violences
faites aux femmes parce qu'en martinique
le taux est vraiment très important les
violences sexuelles la martinique c'est
trois fois plus important qu'en france
mais ça on le sait jamais on le sait et
on sait également que vous prenez
régulièrement votre bâton de pèlerin qu
il a trouvé le chagrine de belline de
perrine et pourtant pourquoi ça ne prend
pas cette mayonnaise très bas parce que
tout simplement parce que nous nous
disons que peut-être que nos femmes
élues ne sont pas si vindicatifs dessus
dans les municipalités que nous sommes
tout à fait prête à lyon sous le nom
breuses défunt vers les consoles us pour
comme le dit non mais noël sont pas très
nombreux sont pas peu nombreuse avec la
parité elles sont à moitié du conseil
municipal de tendance entre pas
davantage mais c'est parce qu'elle je
pense qu'il faudrait qu'elle se
rapproche de nos pour qu'on puisse en
discuter que les formations en action
les formations devraient pas se faire
d'abord vers ces femmes qui se disent on
nous le disons et nous sommes toutes
prêtes à un fer 6 formations et à
discuter avec elles et à les aider et
mettre en place ce qu'on appelle le
j'aime d'un budget thing c'est à dire
que dans les budgets
il y a une ligne transversale sur la
question de l'égalité hommes-femmes et
surtout sur la question des violences
faites aux femmes
il faut un budget danser mais des mêmes
des petites baies petit budget mais même
sans argent peut faire des choses par
exemple 25 novembre
on peut demander à des artistes de la
commune de faire une banderole et à ce
moment là c'est un moyen aussi de
sensibiliser ces personnes là il ya
plein de choses à faire
alors un client habituel est prête à
donner à un paraphe mettre en place des
projets avec avec égalité vous avez des
militantes il ya les actions que vous
menez vous avez le relais dans les
médias vous avez une sympathie
grandissante du public mais c'est donc
politiquement qu'il manque quelque chose
euh oui moi je crois que il ne s'agit
pas seulement de donner des subventions
et qui sont des fois pas donné parce que
il ya des associations qui se plaignent
de n'avoir pas reçu des subventions ce
n'est pas suffisant il faut une
politique volontariste des personnes qui
donne des subventions de la collectivité
dès qu'il est par exemple des rares
collectivités torrio territoriale de la
municipalité et même de la caf de tous
les organismes
c'est à dire que on peut imaginer qu'à
la caf le 25 novembre il un prospectus
un document fleuty mettre sur le grill
non jeudi le 25 novembre par exemple ce
qu'on est en pleine campagne de l'udc
obtient violences faites aux femmes
un prospectus est affiché partout c'est
ces informations de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
si fondamental que ça ne soit pas porté
uniquement par les associations
féministes nous sommes que deux
seulement deux associations féministes
plus comme beat qui est une autre
association qui aussi